you still talk to him do you ever call
him up and say what are you doing Donald
you're crazy
he was on our podcast my wife and I do a
podcast together he guested I've talked
to him on the phone like the New York
Times did a story I mean he called me to
compliment me on the story mm-hmm what
comes up on your speed dial when when
Trump is calling you on the cell phone
what pops up I don't have a speed dial
nothing pops up I have one of those old
phones it's like hello there hello who's
this now is this Donald Trump now I've
seen this he has a flip phone you have a
flip phone now I'll tell you the
advantage of this phone are you selling
this right now no you're making money
off this it's a phone okay you're gonna
hit you press up against your ear you
don't get addicted to it I'm not a dick
doesn't control me I see people I say
people with iPhones are dead they're on
them all the time go to dinner with
people and they're on their iPhones I
don't like it I mean I'm on the internet
I understand technology I accept
technology but certain things I try to
resist right
I miss the typewriter but I mean you
miss the typewriter I love you don't
miss the title I'm innocent
then go buy a typewriter there's tons of
them they're working you bud first of
all I have a typewriter and he'll tell
you the dead do I have a couple of times
right yeah people have typos did you go
get a typewriter he want my why waste
hours at a time writing long letters to
people around here that are absolutely
are they're funny but they're absolute
and cotton white letters he writes long
letter and write useful whether those
are heartfelt yeah I'll write your
letter you Larry I'm gonna write you a
letter on the typewriter and I'm gonna
mail it to you hey by the way yeah I
think mail is extraordinary
I think you put a nice little color you
notice I said not to stamp now you put a
nice little stamp on the thing on the
envelope you're right things out you put
it in a box next day it's there that's
amazing
first of all next day it's not there
Larry
if we get ferret oh hey we can at what
post officer you you're putting it in a
in a mailbox and just not a shoebox
somewhere the next day I never done that
you have romanticized the old ways no
the typewriter was a big problem and
mail took a long time I don't start
talking about a horse we don't want to
ride a horse I did not come here to be
humiliated wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]